bien estamos en el problema número 6 y
déjame escoger un color perfecto para el
problema número 6 este me gusta
el problema número 6 que nos dice lo
siguiente si james es el punto medio de
x zeta así que déjame dibujarte que una
línea emergente que está es una recta y
por aquí tengo a x voy a suponer que
esta es x y por aquí tengo a z por aquí
tengo a z entonces el punto medio de
estos dos por aquí aquí está bien
perfecto entonces si james es el punto
medio de x eta cuál de las siguientes
afirmaciones es verdadera y me dan tres
afirmaciones vamos a ver cuál o cuáles
son verdaderas y la primera me dice lo
siguiente número uno
me dice que se está bien
z esto es exactamente lo mismo que en un
medio de x gent que un medio de x z
perdón de xc está a ser esto cierto
vamos a ver si yo tengo z me refiero a
esta distancia esta distancia de aquí es
10 z y si te das cuenta como es el punto
medio esta distancia es la mitad de toda
esta distancia que tengo aquí que por
cierto es x zeta entonces y ez es un
medio es la mitad de la distancia y ez
esto es correcto entonces hasta aquí
vamos bien y me dice mi número 2 es el
siguiente número 2 un medio de x z
esto tiene que ser exactamente igual que
2 veces x ya que 2 veces x
y esto será cierto un medio de x z es
decir la mitad de esta distancia es 2
veces x y esto no es cierto
xy es la mitad de estas distancias lo
multiplicamos por 2 me da toda la
distancia entera no un medio no la mitad
esto en definitiva no es cierto entonces
vamos a ver qué dice el número 3 el
número 3 me dice lo siguiente 2 veces x
bien esto es igual a x z a x z será
cierto esto déjame ver quién es la
distancia x gent x es esto de aquí esto
de aquí es x es decir la mitad de la
distancia x z y si yo lo multiplicó por
2 tendría esta distancia más esta
distancia lo cual es x está por lo tanto
esto también es cierto 2 veces x y dos
veces esta distancia es la distancia xz
entera y bueno el inciso que tiene como
respuesta el 1 y el 3 es el inciso
así que ya está
perfecto y vamos a hacer mejor el
siguiente problema el siguiente problema
es el problema número 7 así que volvemos
y vamos a poner por aquí problema número
7 este problema me dice lo siguiente si
dos r
esto es igual a 5 veces ese a 5s y por
otra parte yo sé que 5 s es igual a 6
veces este a seis veces este a seis
veces este entonces lo que me preguntan
es cuál es la relación de r con respecto
a t ok
pues aquí vamos a usar al buen euclides
que nos dice que dos cosas iguales a una
tercera son iguales entre sí si dos r es
igual a 5 es en déjame marcar los 12
eres igual a 5 es por otra parte cinco s
es igual a seis tema esto está diciendo
ni más ni menos que dos r que 2 r es
exactamente igual que 6 t
si 12 eres igual a 5 s que esto es igual
a 6
entonces puedo quitar esta parte de aquí
y quedarme con que dos r es igual a 6 t
por si dividido todo entre 2 me va a
quedar que r es igual a 3 t y esta es la
respuesta es el inciso c ya está el
problema número 7 estaba bastante
sencillo si recordamos a euclides y
vamos a ver qué me dice el problema
número 8 guau este se ve interesante
dice un total de pasajeros se van de
viaje por el mundo
déjame escribirlo aquí tengo acá
pasajeros camps pasajeros pasajeros muy
bien y estos k pasajeros se van de viaje
por el mundo cada uno de los autobuses
que los transportarán puede llevar un
máximo de equis pasajeros y eso también
es importante
tengo n autobuses en autobuses auto
cesc y cada uno de ellos tiene una
capacidad de x asientos asientos muy
bien
cada uno de los autobuses que los
transportará puede llevar un máximo de
equis pasajeros tiene x asientos si uno
de los autobuses tiene tres asientos
vacíos
uno de ellos tiene tres asientos vacíos
entonces aquí tengo tres asientos
asientos vacíos
si os muy bien si uno de los autobuses
tiene tres asientos vacíos y todos los
demás autobuses están llenos cuál de los
siguientes incisos representa una
relación verdadera para x en ica
bueno esencialmente lo que aquí dice es
que tengo que llevar a estos k pasajeros
enteros o de otra manera
camps que es la cantidad de pasajeros es
exactamente igual a quién
bueno pues todos estos tienen que estar
en el autobús pero tengo en autobuses y
cada uno de estos en autobuses tiene una
capacidad de x asientos es decir k es
igual a n por x esto porque todos estos
pasajeros tienen que estar en los
autobuses y cada uno de estos autobuses
tiene x asientos k es igual a n por x
pero en el último autobús sobran tres
asientos tengo tres asientos vacíos por
lo tanto aquí acá igual a n por x me
estoy refiriendo a que tuviera en
autobuses con x asientos y todos
estuvieran llenos pero realmente no es
así me sobran 3 asientos entonces a esto
le tengo que quitar 3 asientos
estos tres asientos son los que están
vacíos es decir voy a llenar en
autobuses que cada uno de ellos tiene
que es asiento pero me sobran tres y
esta es la relación de acá m y x que por
cierto es el inciso am así que si está
en mis sencillos y estamos bien aquí
tenemos el problema número 7 el problema
número 8 pues vamos a borrar esto y
vamos a trabajar ahora con el problema
número 9
guau y tengo un buen de líneas así que
déjame hacerlas hambre esta herramienta
y tengo una recta como esta tengo
después otra recta como esta
son parecidas estas dos así más o menos
después tengo una que corta por acá esta
es la recta loca que corto por acá y
después de aquí tengo otra recta pero no
sube exactamente por aquí llega como por
acá perfecto y qué datos me dan me dicen
que esta recta se llama el en esta de
aquí se llama m además me dan el dato de
que l y m son paralelas este ángulo es
de 80 grados 80 grados y este es de 50
grados 50 grados y este es mi ángulo x
este de aquí es x y de hecho que es
justo lo que yo quiero cuánto vale x y
si has visto
una vez mis vídeos de geometría te vas a
dar cuenta que este es uno de los
típicos ejemplos de cazar ángulos o del
juego de los ángulos porque es lo que
hay que hacer es ir cansando poco a poco
todos los ángulos posibles hasta llegar
a x si yo lo que quiero es x vámonos
acercando a x am y para acercarnos a x
si éste va al 80 todo esto todo esto
debe de valer 180 son ángulos
suplementarios y por lo tanto este
ángulo de aquí debe de valer 100 grados
este de aquí debe de valer 100 grados
mientras manera que 100 grados más 80
son 180 grados muy bien y ahora si me
voy para camps a donde llegó bueno llegó
a que esta recta cruza a dos rectas
paralelas y por lo tanto este ángulo
tiene que ser igual a éste
este ángulo y este ángulo son iguales si
este vale 100 grados este también debe
de valer 100 grados son iguales porque
tengo dos rectas paralelas que están
cruzadas por esta línea porque esta de
aquí y ahora
guárdate cuenta de lo siguiente estos
también son suplementarios este este y
este todos estos son suplementarios
porque están arriba de esta línea recta
por lo tanto 100 grados más 50 grados
más algo tiene que ser 180 este algo
este de aquí tiene que valer entonces 30
grados porque 30 grados más 50 grados
más 100 grados son 180 grados y qué
creés ya estoy al ladito de x porque
date cuenta de lo siguiente si esta
recta de aquí me divide
a esta región en dos entonces este
ángulo y este ángulo también son
suplementarios 30 grados más este ángulo
tienen que dar 180 estos me tienen que
dar 180 pero ya tengo aquí 30 grados
por lo tanto x tiene que valer lo que
nos falta para llegar a 180 grados y lo
que nos falta son 150 grados por lo
tanto x tiene que ser igual a 150 grados
de tal manera que estos dos son
suplementarios y ya está quedó perfecto
am y todavía tengo tiempo para ver
problemas números días así que vámonos
el siguiente problema déjenme borrar la
pantalla y poner una nueva capa el
problema número 10 que me dice lo
siguiente déjenme cambiar de color y
dice que tres veces x cuadrada esto es
menor que 3 x x elevado al cuadrado y lo
que me preguntan es
para cuál de los siguientes valores de
los valores que tenemos los incisos esta
afirmación no es cierta para cuál de los
siguientes valores esta desigualdad no
se cumple no es cierta y vamos a ver los
valores tengo el inciso am - 3 el inciso
b a 0 el inciso c tengo un tercio el
inciso d tengo 1 y el inciso y tengo a
ninguno de los anteriores ninguno
tengo un no tengo ninguno y cuál será mi
respuesta pues vamos a probar a ver qué
es lo que pasa en el primer inciso yo
tengo menos 3 entonces 3 que multiplica
a menos 3 elevado al cuadrado esto tiene
que ser menor que 3 que multiplica a
menos 3 que multiplica a menos 3 todo
esto elevado al cuadrado
vamos a ver menos 3 elevado al cuadrado
es 99 por 33 27 27 tiene que ser menor
que menos 3 por 3 esto es lo mismo que
menos 9 menos nueve elevado al cuadrado
es 81 positivo y esto es cierto perfecto
entonces ésta no es vamos a ver la
siguiente
3 que multiplica a 0 elevado al cuadrado
esto tiene que ser menor que 3 que
multiplica a 0 esto elevado al cuadrado
pero 3 que multiplica 0 elevado al
cuadrado es 0 esto tiene que ser menor
que 3 por 0 es decir 0 elevado al
cuadrado cero
y aquí tenemos la respuesta pero no es
menor que 0 0 es igual a 0 pero 0 no es
menor que 0 esto no tiene sentido por lo
tanto el inciso b es la que no cumple
esta desigualdad cuando sustituyó a x
por 0 obtengo que 0 es menor que cero y
esto no es cierto ya está es el inciso b
así que ya me queda muy poco tiempo por
lo tanto mejor nos vemos muy pronto